there's a reason why hey there's a
reason about it why body positivity is
only for women
yes it's not for men
and i don't see women complaining about
them it's not it's not for men
it's only for women because let me ask
you why do you think it's only for women
what is body positivity it's not for men
why do i think it's why do you think
it's only why do you think it's only
encouraged for women not men
you said earlier that women are more and
empowered for example were more
emotional were more empathetic i think
it was the words
i think it boils down to that and i do
think men are a lot tougher on
themselves
i think why don't maybe there's
biological reasons why don't women
support big men why don't we support big
men y'all don't support yourselves
you said women are more pathetic yeah
right so why are they not empathetic
towards the larger men i know my answer
even though i said it in jest it's the
truth you are
empathetic towards you
but we're not we're not talking about
why not men i'm not talking about i'm
saying the reason